cough game resumes peered back welcome
back to the wolf among us let's keep
playing baby hey baby episode 4 in
sheep's clothing I really hope we will
actually see the crooked man your son
I'm curious I it looks like I Nerissa
B wolf have a seat
I walk work are you okay
they were a lick I kid didn't look good
last night I wasn't sure you'd be I'm
fine don't worry about me
of course huff and puff I love that
cigarette breath Haughton puffs
now many people smoke those well
Charette of course he'd smoke - pipes
Thanks
you can start talking yeah something's
almost not a lot that I can talk about
you know that so that spell crane was
trying to break it's not just while
you're at work
what I mean is I don't want to waste
your time but I don't want you wasting
your own time either
right in this dressing room at the
pudding and pie I told you what I was
looking for and you found a way to tell
me you sent me to the open arms maybe
that'll work again you can try I just
why why does she says like that
go ahead it might work
you're here because the crooked man just
sent crane to the bottom of my list of
worries you have something you want to
say about that right these lips are
sealed
well [ __ ] I could answer you just like
that I wouldn't have had to make that
appointment with you no I guess not
how about she taps her cigarettes
twice or one well we have to find our
way through life on our own grasping and
fumbling in the dark
I I used to have friends to help me find
my way but now they're gone and I don't
know what to do
I know what she's talking about but is
this going somewhere hey I don't mean to
be rude though I'm sorry I thought I
could do this I need you to know I want
to help but but it's okay take your time
I'm sorry if I'm wasting your time it's
not like I have much else to do right
now I knew how to say it
ribbons faith war one two yeah I like it
yes it's beautiful
it was it is beautiful that's why you
can't tell me anything
it's the ribbon isn't it
how about we take it off
what what everybody bit you mind if I
just what you can't just stay back her
head will fall off slow down it's all
right
I'm not gonna do anything
please don't sorry
he's got even more awkward okay I get it
I get it girl I owe the ribbons if you
take them all off
comfort
you're welcome Nerissa you're welcome
for that padding that it gets for you
now goddamnit everyone this is the worst
I came here probably snow how didn't
even the death for some Sheriff
can you keep this conversation between
us of course I could be in a lot of
trouble I won't tell anyone
don't worry thank you cuz I'm a
gentleman hips
sorry I just need to talk to the sheriff
for a moment please excuse us one minute
I might have a new lead for you but I
don't know how solid it is beauty and
beast called the office just now they
said they wanted to talk to you about
something I wonder if they've heard
about crane thank you for listening
sheriff you should go on to your next
business I don't think you'll be wasting
your time wait you don't have to go snow
can be really nice was and she can be
the really [ __ ] act sometimes some way
to send a message I don't know did she
tell you I didn't mean to rush her out
did you get anything from her she
couldn't really say anything the magic
that crane was talking about it's in the
ribbon and you can't take the ribbon off
or sound faith and Lily died okay then
good work that's disgusting
so about beauty and beast do you think
there's something to it is this the
right place to look what kind of things
that The Crooked Man or do you think
they just heard about last night and
they're scared about what's been gonna
go over this whatever it is I'm sure
they called for a reason exactly those I
better go check it out we're gonna do it
anyway then I'm yeah whatever
you know pewdie came to me a while back
really she was looking for financial
assistance I told her there was nothing
I could do and
and she said that meant she'd have to go
somewhere else that was not nice pigby
you don't think she meant that she was
going to go to The Crooked Man
do you know and I would explain why they
called we need to solve this before
something else happens
who knows what someone's gonna be an
elevator
nope I have other matters to attend to
what she's not being on his either
Oh snippety snoo they don't know what I
think about dad okay butan B's apartment
nice cell prediction skills wait they
live in this hell oh how he has the
voice of
Oh
what do you want cuddles well you're
just going around knocking on doors you
called right
or was it beauty why would I call you
because the very breath listen Steve
I've had a shitty night I think you're
the only one and I really don't want to
deal with the runaround snow said you
called and wanted to talk to me well I
didn't call must have been beauty she's
been surprising me a lot lately so have
you baby yet with all the sneaking
around and secrets somehow I'm still the
bad guy in this I've had to hear about
it all night long from her who is it
who's there you don't want to talk can
you just get beauty for me I don't know
is it safe to turn my back he's gonna
open
it's your pal Big B have a nice place
Big B please excuse us for just a minute
well I guess is not a castle in private
yes let's though they wanted to thank
the main yes I really do have the
smallest apartment in the woodlands the
electric bill is for that thing no I
wouldn't wonder that at all that's when
he used to be happy it was a merry tale
about living in a past do you want to
keep fighting about that or do you want
to try to sort this out why did I do
that and don't do that
sorry it's been a long night yeah you
know what they say
now I'm sure ease of marriage come with
centuries of baggage I gotta say your
place it looks expensive what do you
mean by that these no really I want to
know what are you trying to say huh did
you come to give us decorating tips
nothing it's a nice place you got here
that's all I'm saying thanks but that's
really not why I call oh really you're
in calling for that something about that
loan you took out from The Crooked Man I
didn't know what else to do we should
deal with this on our own
he's just going to complicate I called
him here and I want to see if he can
help us out why are you being like this
I'm just trying to do what's best for us
that's all I ever do I'd like to help
you but I can't do anything if you don't
tell me what's going on it's about
timing first what if we did have
something to say about the crooked man
what if we talk and you don't get it and
all this comes back on us we'd be
risking a lot most seen what happens
when you cross the crooked man and I
don't know if it's worth it if you can't
give us certain ya assurances we're just
looking for a little peace of mind in
this I can protect you but only if you
tell me what I need to know and that
business details
no more stonewalling we aren't
and just tell me what's going on here
look we're used to a certain kind of
lifestyle okay we couldn't just give
that I never meant for it to get like
this it's just that we had nowhere else
to turn and we got in over our heads
there's not a lot of work out there who
would we be if we just lived like like
what it's fancy pantsy people aren't you
gonna answer that the [ __ ] was that no I
don't worry about it now come on just
wrong number really I think we're one
digit off from some pizza place fine I'm
sure you can handle whatever this is on
your own I'll see you later
please Big B wait then don't [ __ ] me
we've been getting horrible phone calls
it's the crooked man's people trying to
collect and we aren't safe even in our
own home we owe some money finally like
that was an Army Air about is how can I
find the crooked man who do I talk to
where do I go
you know I don't wanna keep on that's
where I borrow the money all right call
me thank good man's behind that place
thank you I'd overheard people talking
to Jersey about loans before so when I
needed money that's where I went I
didn't know what to do wanna know about
him what do you deal with Jersey you
know the Jersey Devil is anything that
slimy prick I didn't realize he was back
on this side of the river and those
Tweedles were always going in and out
probably dropping off a loan payment
they squeezed out of some poor fable but
never the Crooked Man
only it's just regular fables I can see
now that it was a mistake but I'm not
the only one who goes there you know I
saw the woodsman Zach's there just the
other day it was in a display case so
everyone is in my guess he's hit hard
times too there's a lot of that going
around I can't imagine he has a lot of
marketable skills
yeah and bloody mary must go through
there she had what he Zach's last night
trying to chop my damn head off with it
maybe if you go there you can sort some
things out I guess I'll go check out the
lucky pawn if I can't track down the
crooked man there maybe I can make
enough noise that the crooked man will
come find me
hold on pygmy don't go there sounds like
you're just going to get beauty in
trouble mind what I was it we gonna do
you know that butcher's shop the cut
above no it's the place on Tubman Street
same block is the baker and the
candlestick maker
well I've been delivering packages from
there for a while Mike and ASD it's for
The Crooked Man
I don't think it's meat in the packages
you gotta understand I needed work
listen to me very carefully you ever
deliver to the crooked man can you give
me an address
no I delivered to places all over town
but never to the man himself it never
seems to be heading to the same place
but it always comes out of the butcher
shop
how did you get involved with this Johan
the butcher called he had a problem with
the refrigeration unit one night but
when I finished it was your pal Mary who
showed up to pay me she said I was
reliable she liked that
it's the only thing I've been able to
pick up and it's still not enough
I don't want beauty to have to work
especially not where she was its Mary
you deal with Bloody Mary is there no
Johan is the one who hands over the
packages day to day but I've seen her
around there gia gets under my skin you
know I I try to avoid her but I don't
need to tell you what she's a damn right
you don't I don't need a rundown on her
reputation if Mary works out of there I
need to look into it I just wanted to
provide for beauty give her the kind of
life she deserves good job I knew that
shouldn't employ it's like this scraping
to get by none of us should we were
royalty once we were accustomed to a
certain lifestyle all we want is to make
this place feel a little bit like home
you wouldn't understand baby
no ain't you I don't need to understand
it's not my [ __ ] job don't understand
my job is to keep Fabletown safe
so where are you going if this all goes
sideways I'd like to know where it's
coming from
so we get to choose I think oh god what
do you bet think you know that what's
your shot the cut above the thing is I
don't think it's meat in the packages
mmm that could be good we cut around
into marrying that's where I borrow the
money the crooked man's behind that
place I think butcher shop you know yeah
let's go I don't know what the crooked
man is hiding at that butcher shop you
know baby once you show up there word is
gonna spread there may be nothing left
for you to see if you go to the lucky
pawn after well I guess I'll find out I
like this gets me pumped girl I don't
know what you're planning to do when you
find the crooked madman but is there any
way you could help us out I thought I
was out but yeah I get it well maybe you
can make this go away
oh yeah I'm gonna bad really appreciate
it what do you say can you help us out
you're asking me to kill him aren't you
is that what you think I do no of course
not I don't know how you get that idea
is it we know that the crooked man is
dangerous to all a Fabletown
I'm gonna do my job
lucky for you that might just solve your
problems anyway oh thank you Big B I'm
sure you'll do the right thing I don't
understand why beasts is so pointless he
doesn't it looks pretty bad it makes me
I mean how long saying how that works
was all right butchering
oh I don't care
is that big be
I smoke whenever I wanna check out the
cold drinks like Cola and leaf and lemon
lime a lot of lemon lime lemon line is
my favorite let's check out the menu
they got Oakhill basa and salami and
bacon and honey ham and whoa let's take
one huh empty either he's got a whole
lot of customers or he doesn't have any
I would go with their last one right
yeah so maybe they are doing other [ __ ]
here frozen meat mmm very appetizing
frozen solid we want to eat this
let's go in
oops well he doesn't look too bad
big beep wolf well hello there yeah like
I'm Sheriff like I get for you you
interested in a particular cut um let's
see what do we have in stock let's uh
let's see where we got here
thanks take one special New York Strip
oh I can have some wild boar in tomorrow
if you like sirloin ribs roast
tongue got some tongue here I know
you're lying there he hangs around here
I want to talk to her i I don't know
what you mean what you see is what you
get
just meat you don't find anything else
so we just we know more wholesale and
meatpacking that walk-up service I'd
like to help you really I would but
there's nothing here
and what if I do find something here
because you haven't been straight with
me
really sheriff you won't we'll see about
that yeah I got my nose Sheriff I uh huh
huh huh huh huh smokes Alvin he's gonna
go and hang something real sorry oh [ __ ]
I just got to go check hit the alarm
Oh anywhere I'll be right back butcher I
just have to go see I gotta hit the
alarm go go go go go hit the lam son of
a bee sting [ __ ]
oh I love these feeds wonderful
I don't want to say anything but I'm
coming to help you
what's the problem I'm just coming back
didn't really think we're gonna stop
since Lee what the [ __ ] he's gonna die a
horrible death I'm gonna shave my chest
hair and put it on this I'm gonna [ __ ]
my butt hair I clicked the wrong one
[ __ ] it it doesn't matter how many
[ __ ] fingers yeah how's it going over
here he's gonna get me killed things I
do what are you hiding behind that door
what really he got surprised by his feet
please pick me please stop me what
happened to sheriff don't kill me
sheriff I don't want to die please
please stop kill me you don't talk I
might have to do just that isn't that
what you want Johan Johan please don't
have to do that I'm dead either way
they said to me Johan you can keep your
life and lose your shop or lose both
what would you do it was a simple choice
to make in the moment easy even when
they got down to hook in the deep freeze
they
you mean Mary Bloody Mary this isn't my
shop anymore that crew took it from me a
long time ago crews the crooked men's
people yeah Apple D and um and mental
case Bloody Mary you want to talk about
the real butcher and it's her not me
this is her place I'm telling you they
muscled in on me to cover my storage and
delivery a long time ago all cause of
that heat wave that summer was even
hotter than this one
I let Mary in those porkers stay cold in
the meat locker one day playing cards
having a great time I guess they were
sizing the place up shows what I get for
being nice and bald
I'm just a victim in this I don't know
what they do back there I swear and I
don't want to know well we're about to
see what's back there and then we'll see
if I believe you
exactly yeah I knew this would happen
didn't know where
all right what do you guys think is
gonna be in there
I hope potatoes [ __ ] right okay this
main they're making drugs is that it or
Glamour's fake Glamour's that would be
answered a lot of questions
oh yeah oh so there were people back
here and now they ran mind Koch we'll
have to get after day you know what time
it is breath I'm sorry I know you were
really into it but I gotta end it here
now would be a great time to leave a
like if you enjoyed this episode and
I'll see you and your beautiful face
yeah did you know it is tomorrow stay
awesome